okay thank you very much
uh licensing officer can i welcome
everybody to
this licensing subcommittee for
wednesday the 16th of december to 2020.
um we've just got one item to consider
this afternoon
which is an application for the grant of
a new premises license
under section 17 of the licensing act
2003
for a vessel at bourbon street barge the
old boatyard
edge lane stretford m328
hw so
so just do some introductions i'm
councillor david jarman i'll be chairing
the meeting i've got
councillors brotherton and but who are
members of the committee with me and
we've got uh legal legal officer
licensing and democratic services
officers on the on the call today
and it'll become apparent as the meeting
goes on just
just to who's who um
now have we got the applicant mr tim
ross
yes welcome mr ross
and we've got two representations from
members of the public uh we have a susan
mia's
and a bernadette mcgreevy yeah
absolutely
all right you're bernadette i'm
brilliant hi
welcome to the meeting hi hi do we have
susan mia's
muted oh she's muted can you
put your microphone on miss mia's please
okay
i can hear you there you are i can hear
you now
okay all right i think we've got
everybody here so we'll we'll
we'll press on with the meeting um
[Music]
so the process that we're following is
that we will we're going to hear from
the licensing officer first to outline
um
the application then the applicant to
speak in support of his application
um we'll hear i think what we can hear
from is there's only two representatives
we could probably hear from both if
that's okay
with the applicant that's if you both
wish to speak
or there's only one of you yeah i'm
happy to speak if the questions have not
been
answered as we go along okay all right
and then obviously uh well i'll ask you
to summarize so starting with
yourself as a representative and then
the applicant and
and you you you both have two minutes
each to sum up
um the case for and against
um the legal officer will then give a
briefing to the subcommittee
um and then we'll go into a closed
session to determine the application
uh which will take a few minutes so
imagine
and then we will join the the main
meeting to
to give the determination
and the the the outcome will be
given in writing to the the applicant
within uh
five working days of this meeting
okay so uh karen as the licensing office
do you want to
outline the application please yep thank
you chair
so i'm kieran hinschliff licensing
officer for driver council
under section 18 of the licensing act
2003
members are requested to determine an
application for a new premises license
in respect of a vessel
at bourbon street barge the old boat
yard edge lane in stratford
having regards the representations
received and the requirements
promote the four licensing objectives
the following options are open to the
licensing subcommittee
you can grant the application in full on
the terms and conditions contained
within the application
to include any applicable mandatory
conditions you can grant the application
as above but
modified to such an extent as considered
appropriate to satisfy any relevant
representations
and promote the licensing objectives or
you can reject the application
uh this report has um appendices
attached
which take the form of the application
itself and
additional photographs of the vessel and
covered
risk assessments there is the blue
notices and newspaper advert for
compliance with the
consultation and then we also have
conditions agreed with environmental
health officer all the representations
received from other persons
and then the last appendices there
appendix there is
an amendment to the application dated
the 16th of november 2020.
a premises license is required in
respect of any premises where it is
intended to conduct one or more of the
four licensed activities these being the
sales supply of alcohol
regulated entertainment the provision of
late night refreshment
this application was submitted by
timothy ross in respect for a vessel
located at bourbon street basement barge
the old boat yard in stratford the
applicant has applied for the following
hours
it's 10 a.m until midnight for the
supply of alcohol
both on and off sales live music
recorded music
performance of dance and films and then
we have late night refreshment from 11
o'clock till midnight
and the opening hours are 10 a.m until
half past midnight
the applicant has included seasonal
variations
the application has been properly made
and all the procedures correctly
followed
the application including uh photographs
of the
of the vessel uh the recovery restricted
plan and a code risk assessment was also
included
that's all attached to appendix a
photographs of the blue notice in place
and a copy of the newspaper advert
are also attached as appendix b in terms
of the background and the history of the
premises
the vessel is not currently licensed the
applicant
has described the premises as a
purpose-built
passenger vessel formerly known as the
martin emperor
with a uk passenger certificate
classification
of uk class category of class v
passenger numbers are 50 recruit minimum
of two and maximum people on board
of 54. there is seizing for 50 people
a public toilet two entrance exits and
two fire exits
firefighting equipment rescue and
evacuation in line with the mca schedule
the vessel has been operating as a
licensed passenger vessel for several
years with the bent with the within the
pendle
council district prior to being
purchased
the vessel's permanent home port is at
the above address
in stratford however it cannot be
permanently
moored there the long-term operating
plan
covered 19 restrictions permitting will
be that the vessel will operate
as a floating venue for both ticketed
and non-ticketed events
as well as private hire the vessel will
travel between different locations to
facilitate
this unique venue experience for example
it will collect a wedding party for
point a
and take them to point b facilitating a
unique wedding breakfast experience
tours from locations in the northwest to
old trafford and historic
tours along the leads to liverpool canal
the operating schedule um
members you're obviously familiar with
operating schedules but but for everyone
present
the operating schedule is completed by
the applicant it contains additional
measures
um than the non-mandated unmanned
mandatory conditions
and these measures are to illustrate how
they propose to promote the four
licensing objectives
as required by the provision of the
licensing act they are listed below
and included uh within the body of
report and they'll be attached to any
conditions
that they could be attached to any
license should it be granted
of these conditions um throughout the
consultation process
i i just want to bring attention uh to
the members condition
uh seven on the general which was added
as an amendment to the application and
that's that passengers must not embark
on disembark
from bourbon street barges home port and
then further
conditions that were agreed during the
consultation period with the
environmental health officer
which is under prevention of public
nuisance and their conditions four and
five
their related noise levels from
amplified sound
will be reduced to a level which will
not constitute nuisance and noise
sensitive properties and no external
speakers will be fitted to the vessel
in terms of the consultation all the
responsible authorities were
were consulted um including the
environment agency
and the canal and river trust and the
maritime and coast guard agency
um on the direction of the canal and
river truss appeal holdings were also
consulted
because they own this section of canal
of the consultees that were identified
one representation was received from the
pollution control authority
which is the environmental health
officer and conditions were agreed to
satisfy this representation
and that's attached to appendix c these
are also included in the operating
schedule under the prevention of public
nuisance
and the full representations we'll
receive from other persons concerned
with public nuisance
and these are attached as appendix d a
copy of the report and all
representations
received have been sent to the applicant
in terms of illegal considerations
conditions may only be attached to a
premises license where they're deemed
appropriate for the promotion of
licensing objectives
they must be proportionate and not
duplicate any existing provisions
contained in other legislation
and justification behind a refusal or
the attachment of conditions
must be given to the applicant uh there
is a right of appeal to the magistrate's
court
within 21 days from the date the
applicant is notified of the decision
the licensing subcommittee i am perhaps
a lengthy report
but thank you for your patience chair
that concludes
thank you mr henchford uh does does
anybody have any questions for the
licensing officer at this stage
oh no no not the licensing not knowing
just about
obviously the process and the the
license
aspect of the application um
therefore if we can hear from mr ross if
you'd like to speak to his
his application and give us the details
of
all the operational details and any
information to support
his application today please
mr ross you think you're on fire you're
right
good afternoon um yes regarding the um
department basement barge it's the
second vessel um
in our fleet um where our first
boat was the um dry barge which had been
operating for over 10 years now
and for and it is actually moored at the
same rate yes as homeport moon is at the
same location as where we're proposing
for the basement bars to be located um
that we are we tend to operate this
vessel as a touring vessel and it will
not be
it will not be picked up and and
disembarking um
passengers from and on within the area
of where
it's home or in is it's not a suitable
location for it in any way shape or form
and not just for the fact that the
geographics of the area but also
the fact that it's high residential
population in the area so
it was never our intention we dry about
that to happen and never has happened it
won't be our intention in relation to
um the the new vessel we're going to be
operating
and the vessel itself will be operated
for a predominantly seating and it's got
seating for fifth day it's licensed for
50
and the general operation is going to be
around tours
and wedding parties to and from venues
and tours too from sporting stadiums
like anfield
and chester race courses uh old trafford
cricket ground
old trafford football ground and also
historical tours up and down uh the
canal networks
the bridgewater canal system and once
it's open and up and running
the the manchester to rochester canal
once that once a redevelopments in
north of manchester been finished and
as is with what happens with our
existing boat
and the operating system and the way
we're going to operate the vessel
has been and a tried and tested system
which we put in place and operated
for a number of years and over the
period of time we have been working and
we've never had any issues or problems
not only with the canals and rivers
trust
but with the mca and all the local
authorities where we operate the boat
that happened at the present um and we
hope that that will continue in the
future
um we have and we do understand
people's concerns in relation to the
objections that was
um put to us and i think that the
the conditions that's been suggested by
ourselves and and
gone through with the licensing officer
and agreed to um
should we hope being be enough to
actually leave people's concerns and
fears
um like i said over the 10 years we've
plus we've operated but we've never had
problems and issues in relation to noise
pollution
and nuisances and unruly behavior from
people in and around
the world when it's been you know on on
the tour
but really i think that's kind of rather
than
going into in-depth into the technical
side of it in relation to
um rescue and resource from
uh local authorities and and fire
service and
fire and rescue and the canals and river
trust it it's kind of that's where we
stand
in the vessel uh we did we are dealing
to all the conditions set down by the
council
trust as part of our operation license
under the mcu
and also and the legislation that was
set down
and the conditions have been set down by
um
the uh liverpool inspectors
for who come to inspection certification
for which means
to re-license it as a commercial vessel
for
the next five years
okay mr ross is that it for your
submission right
um obviously um
it really begs the question then what we
need to establish what we're actually
licensing
here so
the vessel will be moored at some point
at the old boat yard at edge lane
now each vessel under under the 2003 act
for vessels have to have a home port
mooring
and commercial record pill holders have
stated that
where because they the commercial
commercial vehicle
sorry the commercial vessel mooring is
um
where the driveway where you stay for
the last application that's why we have
to do the application from there
the license is is to cut is with traffic
um
council but it's to cover it anywhere
within the canals
canals network all right thanks for that
so
while you're moored at uh edge lane you
you won't
there won't be basically a party going
on on the boat
it will be completely empty no maybe no
no no there'd be no static use of of the
vessel for
um functions and so and there will be no
impact and disembarking
and it's homeport whatsoever
so it begs the question then where are
you actually embarking and disembarking
um we will be embarking this marking
from pre
pre-determined locations for certain set
tours
so at the moment historically we pick up
at castlefield
and we also pick up from anfield and we
also pick up from old trafford
um in relation to tours at the moment
and we pick up down
this vessel is licensed to go into the
map will be licensed and like going to
the manchester ship canal
so it'll be able to pick up other
locations in and around the manchester
ship now
whereas the dry barge at the moment that
vessel isn't licensed to go onto the
manchester ship canal
for tours so it's not it's a different
type of vessel
okay so while you're at why you're
actually in operation
could you could you just say what sort
of which stretch of i mean presumably
it's predominantly the bridgewater
yeah and did you say the leads liverpool
yeah you know and then hopefully in
future the manchester ship canal
yes so to what extent will you be to
where's the sort of most southern extra
extremity on the bridgewater canal that
you'll be operating
and i think at the moment our we are in
consultation with the company
to take out historic going down as far
as chester at the moment
because it there's an historical goal on
the canal
system as far as chester and and then
long term they're looking at possibly
going and doing a viaduct tours
pick up and drop off from locations in
around the northwest
and taking people on viaduct tours as
far as south wales as far as the
northwest side
okay and then and going in the other
direction northwards where do you
envisage
the the you know the furthest extent
of the operation would be on the leeds
liverpool
we're looking at picking up some when we
purchased the vessel we also purchased
the
the ongoing contracts that the the
previous operator
around colon so we'd also be taking
tours up and around there as well
so that'll be taking on the historic
tours that that boats operate for 25
years up and around that area
and we'll also once obviously it is
dependent on how long the time scale is
for the
manchester rochester the rockstar can
also be to be done
troops will be going up there as well uh
up and around the old and
rockstar areas and around the canal
networks going as far as
um hitman white and um home first finale
is about that
okay thanks for that so you're you're
the dps so will you be on
on the boat at all times when it's in
operation
i will i may be there but we also have
within the company we have three
personal licence holders so it'd be
either me or one of the personal iso
over there but they're also
under the under the canals river trust
and mcu
licensing there has to be a skipper as
well so
um there'll be a full-time skipper on
the boats all the time as well
so how many staff will you have on on
the boat
if it if it's if it's um a standard if
it's not a school tour
then it will be um for staff
school tour then that'll be increased to
six and the capacity will be reduced to
48 of attendances
so and that'll allow for our students
and teachers as well so it will vary
we have to have two extra we have to
have an extra first aid officer on board
and um another member of staff when we
then we've got children
so if you're doing a school tour you
know that'll be
so before it public and sick staff okay
so it'll be either four or six at all
times that you're in operation
that's right yeah okay i'll just ask uh
any
of my panel colleagues if they have any
questions for you
uh councillor brotherton has a question
thank you thanks chef can i just get it
clear in my mind about
the home port presumably you've got the
moorings from the bridgewater canal
company it's that at the
boat boatyard yes yes so the boat will
be
the barge will be even when it's not in
use it'll be moored up
usually um historically the
the boats will only be there when
they're getting um
servicing so unless they have to go into
a dry dock
for a service they'll only be going
there for um
for service periods only that as the dry
bars does
nine times out of ten because because we
could be doing a tour say for instance
um in my castle field in manchester on
the monday
going up and down to say for instance
the the war museum
um that could take several hours through
the day
but the next day we may be somewhere
else out on the wednesday we may be up
at home
and it'll take a full day to get up to
where we're picking up to take a
a tour trip up to home so there will be
days when the boat
won't the vessel won't be used but it
must have been transit to another
location
but well it's not being used at all
it'll be
mowing down at castle field as well
because that's a different type of
vessel it's got limited areas in which
you can travel on the canals and the
manchester ship canal network you can't
travel unless you
sorry as the sun it's got a limited
touring capacity that one
um and it's predominantly it is
predominantly up
up along the bridgewater canal to
trafford and then around the end of
private functions yeah just changing the
truck
if i for example wanted to hire your
boat for a tour
what the chairman said how would we
arrange that would you
say you don't you'd have to come to a
certain point to pick up the party and
come back or yes but most i pick up a
marina point our
pre-determined location that's preset
and
and the if it's a new lot if it's kind
of a virgin route for us
then what we'd have to do is we'd have
to then go through
a process where we contact the local
fire and rescue service and say okay
this is this vessel this is its catholic
creation this is the identification of
the crust
issuing them with uh photographic
evidence of the vehicle
and given the route and part of that
route will include
the the location where we're gonna
embark and disembark from
but also give them um what's called
rendezvous points so there may be a
number of points along the route where
it would
where it'd be kind of defined where if
there was an issue or a problem with the
vessel
and the service had to attend these are
the points wearing and all that's pre
predetermined before it so it's kind of
there isn't just a case all we want to
put we live near the canal such and such
supports you want to pull up our house
and take it here
did it there was a process has to be put
in place it's not as
it's not as simple as just kind of a
taxi service type system
yeah that's what we're trying to get out
really yeah that no there isn't
i understand where you come from but
there is a process has to be put in
place
yeah so thanks for that thank you chad
all right counselor but do you have any
questions for the applicant
has he got his microphone on cancel a
book
sorry about that now the just to confirm
the
uh the place that we're talking about is
this the old boat yard is where those
that mooring is isn't it for five
roughly about five longboats
um to those places where these
these residents live yes i think it's
the area that's just been
um had a lot of landscaping done by peel
holdings
um and just declare a lot of rubbish and
refuge and they've now got a new
uh boatyard manager in there um who's
operating
um some repair services from down there
i think that that's the second uh
business that's gonna be operator from
what i've been told but yes it's in that
area there
right and that business is intended to
be working normal hours or
is it we'll we'll be up if we're going
to be down there it'll be working under
normal
nine to five conditions we won't be
working evenings and weekends on
on the boats down there i said if
there's any major repairs that we're
going to
go into a dry dock because it is a big
vessel yeah and
the main access uh is
that uh road that leads into it from the
that street there isn't it we were
talking about
since stevenson road close road
that's not a vehicle access that's a
pedestrian access yeah yeah
if people if people were going in and
out from to
from the boats would they be coming that
way or would they be using the car park
which is uh
alongside as well there wouldn't be
customers that i would because he's not
operating from that point
it would be people servicing the vehicle
presumably staff
members right so can we can we say that
there will be no activity of retail or
you know
a hospitality activity at that point you
know
from that morning
mr ross doesn't have to answer that yeah
i mean
we've already suggested that as a
conditional license that they'd be
going back and disembarking by members
of the public
um onto the onto the vessel at his home
mooring
and i think that kind of covered it but
there be will be the window there'll be
no active there'll be no
commercial activities carried out on
it's home whatsoever do you do you have
a specific look uh
point mooring point at that designated
for you or
okay wherever there's a space it's it's
basically i think
from the information we have this
there's four there's four locations for
commercial vehicle moorings
and and johnny children's been allocated
and both them was ourselves
at the moment all right
in terms of the other locations that
you've got have you had to
uh apply for license you've got licenses
for those locations or
um we're going for a licensing
process with um appeal holdings who
manage the bridgewater canal system and
the canals and river trust
process is ongoing at the moment and
they are subsequent
um conditions in relation to um
operating a commercial vessel
which are as per the bit as the vessel
was previously which
previous operator so it's just a change
you use a change in change of use
i see mcu yeah
can i one for the uh the officer
here can you just give us an idea of how
many complaints there has been or
objections there has been
for this uh application application
there's only
one so there's there's lots of different
licenses that this this
businessman needs to operate is
his business that that vessel so
there'll be lots of different licenses
um which are issued by the likes of the
canal and the river trust and the mca
there's only one premises license that's
going to be issued
or that that's been applied for and that
is necessary to be applied for
and that's that that will be for
trafford council so the other
four or five ports that you you're going
to stay at
they'll all still come back to the the
this premises license
even if it is in manchester or liverpool
or whatever it might be
so effectively if if there are
complaints at those premises
then the environmental health officers
or the licensing officers for that local
authority will
will come to trafford council and it
will be for for our
um our responsible authorities to to
investigate because the license is held
by us
in terms of to answer your question uh
about the number of rejections
you had an initial objection from the
environmental health officer
and but that was satisfied with
conditions there was two conditions that
were added um
in the prevention of public nuisance
category which related to the locations
for speakers they didn't want any
outside speakers
and they also wanted to set a level the
applicants agreed to that
and then we've also got four other
representations that have been made by
other persons uh they're all maintained
and
uh they've got the opportunity to speak
they've all been invited to here i know
we've got we've got two today but
they've all been invited to the hearing
and uh and i know all four of those
are still a still legitimate um
representation
has there been any from the other side
of the canal you know they've got the
the terrorists turret traffic grove is
it the back end of
trafford grove has there been anything
from that side
um i can i can double check but the it's
just those addresses that are on there
on there i'll double check that for you
i think there's been a there's been a
letter from or an email sorry from
the flats of the airdressers on edge
lane
somebody the person that wrote the email
put that into the email that they lived
above the flat so
it's directly opposite right they were
quite quite relevant really i suppose
have you finished your question question
yes i thank you chad yeah
okay thank you can i just ask uh mr ross
about
the security of the site could you just
briefly explain
the arrangements for security just you
know basically to stop unauthorized
people getting into the site and
uh you know doing uh doing the um
unwanted things to the boat in terms of
breaking in or vandalism or anything
um the the actual site itself um
has got limited security um the vessel
itself has got um
an alarm system on it um steel doors
and um it had and it has internal stills
it's still bulkheads so basically
outside of outside the seating area the
rest of the vessels that's a lot to
lock behind steel bulkheads and so it's
quite cisco
vessel and it's all right it is glazed
um around around both sides around the
seating area and but it's all
it's all tough and tempered glass and so
they're not that easy to get into
um in relation to what peel holdings
intentions are long term for the
security of that area
and i'm not too sure after requiring the
worst talk about them
after the landscaping been done and kind
of within next
over 2021 onwards that was looking at
some
additional security and fencing and
around the area for there and the
marine the residential marine it's on uh
that's adjacent to it but
what their plans are i'm not sure to be
quite honest
yeah i mean i'd say that the actual yard
itself it looks
pretty inadequate as far as security
goes i mean i
i just say that's their responsibility
so
best of luck with getting them to do
something about that
yeah my experience appeal holdings but
yes yeah
well it would help if it was a bit made
a bit more secure in the circumstances
i think just one last question from me i
think you said in your operating
schedule that
if any if anybody was getting too drunk
then
then you'd refuse to serve them
i mean obviously on a boat it's a bit
different than a pub where if they got a
bit aggressive or a bit awkward you
couldn't just eject them could you
you know what what sort of plans
process do you have in place for for
dealing with people
who if that team basically had too much
to drink and becoming
aggressive and or even violent
well i have to say that and i'll keep
hopping back to it but
i've said over this over the 10 years
that plus that we've been operating
the the dry batch and it's very very
rare i mean
the the tours we do is not they're not
they're not really kind of events and
activities where
it's mass drinking and and we have
we have a robust system in place that if
people do attend
the vessel if they've got if before
they've got if they've been drinking if
they've been drinking prior to arrival
to what if the worst way they won't be
allowed to attend
um or embark upon the vessel but
i think we have we have a staffing
system and
the bar staff are quite adverse into in
relation to
uh excessive drinking um i think if
someone came to
a simple example is if someone came to
the bar and the doctor had too much to
drink
we just said i'm sorry but we think
you've had too much to drink
there's a bottle of water so there's a
cup of tea or a cup of coffee go and sit
down
have that and then if you're feeling if
you feel still feeling a bit worse away
in half an hour then
i think it's going to kind of end in a
night for yourself in amazing to
what you're drinking but otherwise it's
kind of
our staff not only operate on there but
the opera
they have got all well experienced it
within our events and festivals that
we've run
and we kind of it's it's it's it's bread
and butter to them
how how to deal with people without
sound maybe one or two
drinks too many are getting to that
point where they've had
it's gonna be they may become an issue
um yeah
i take on board there is that element of
the fact that
when there is a you're actually out on a
tour
then you can't say well so we're going
to pull over and throw it off the boat
and obviously if it if it's a medical or
or
an issue where it's a um
another member of publix at risk then
emerging service will be called and we
pull over to one of the rendezvous
points and burden services be asked to
attend
as per the procedures regarding fire
with the rescue system that we have in
place and which is set down by the mca
and the canals and rivers trust
so we utilize that system uh whereas if
we had to have someone taken off the
boat
but like it says in in the ten years
plus it's never been it's never
arisen
we have we have we have a procedure in
place that we would utilize
our voluntary points to take somebody
off the boat and then
have dealt with from there okay thanks
for that mr ross um
mr hinchcliffe you have any questions
for the applicant
no chair thank you okay then can i can i
ask the representatives if
they have any questions just um we just
limit limited to questions at this stage
not
making a statement so does anybody have
any any of the representatives have any
questions
about what mr ross has said in support
of his application
sorry was i heard somebody then who's
the mayor
miss mia's yes please go ahead
[Music]
no um no singing no alcohol
no people on the boat it's just going to
be there
perhaps service um
is that right sorry i broke up
you broke up after you said perhaps
well i'll start again um
the the boat is the barge is going to be
moored there
yes at times yes
there's no people on the boat other than
the uh well that's close to the person
in
the bride's um
people want on it for entertainment
it's only going to be used well it's
moving up and down the canal
is that right yes
it won't be a case i will pick people up
at another location
come and pull up to that point at our
home port have a party and then take
them back
that won't be happening that's not
that's not going to be happening
there will be no the boat will not be
used by members of the public
while it's in his homeport his homeport
is only for
service and maintenance purposes
um do it like i said there's a secure
stores in the boat um so it'd be minimal
it'd be minimal and it's it's very it's
a steel it's a steel room
within the boat behind bulkheads um
which can't be seen from
from outside okay
sounds okay thank you
okay um ms mcgreevy do you do you have
any questions for that
oh sorry no it's not really a question
it's just to to say that our
understanding was that that
the whole barge would be would be moored
there permanently and
activity the party would be happening
down the road from us but clear you've
made it clear that that's not the case
but it's just been moored for
maintenance
thank you okay then
therefore does do one of you like to put
your
representation or um
[Music]
obviously you may need you may want to
significantly modify it from your
first representation um
with with what what you said tonight but
if you could if you could just put what
your position over
um one one or both of you please help
i'll be at the application yeah i think
as i say our our concerns were that the
party was happening here
and it would be moored here permanently
and we would have the noise and the
destruction disruption caused by that
you've spoke very clearly about what's
going to happen
um and to be honest if it's just being
moored for maintenance
uh purposes and for no other reason then
i actually think don't think i have any
objections that you know
at this point i can tell you that i feel
comfortable
to tell you that on behalf of another
neighbor that i speak for as well
if there's no other disruption you can
guarantee there's no other disruption
other than the maintenance
okay it's not really a disruption okay
miss mcgreevey that's that's helpful
um do you have any
objections to the application
no i i agree with what mr griebe has
said
so if it's just for maintenance
it isn't really going to be a problem
for the residents yeah
so no that's it
okay
sorry uh yeah i was saying as there's no
objections
from the represent from the
representatives is it any need to
actually
have a closed session where we need to
make a decision it's
uh there's no objections and it seems
pretty straightforward really
yeah there are still written objections
that you'll need to consider for those
people that haven't attended today
okay uh
you're back on the universe sorry is
there anything
objectives would like to say before we
we hear from the applicant
in summary please uh can i just say
that i've emailed about three times
and it wasn't made clear in the email
but
it was just going to be ignored it
thought about the alcohol
the music and i think that's why people
got the impression
it was going to be more there
permanently and it would
and also where the notices were put
um on the fence around the boat yard
you would only ever see those if you
walk round it which
you don't um the people who lived across
the road across the canal
they wouldn't have any idea and i don't
understand why they didn't get
notifications
i know it was in the newspaper but
people don't buy newspapers
and we don't get free newspapers
so i think that's something that needs
looking at
well i'm afraid that they could they
satisfy the legal requirement
for the documents and we we hear this
with
virtually every application but that's
all basically
they needed to do i don't know if mr
hinchcliff
wants to add anything about about that
but they did they didn't satisfy the
legal requirement for note
for the notices yeah i don't think it's
adequate that's all i'm saying
i don't understand where you're coming
from
i think um you know there is a raised
expectation now that
um you you may get noticed from the
applicant themselves who notify
neighbours or
or indeed um perhaps
some sort of notification from the local
authority but
the the statutory provision in the
licensing act is
they need to have the notice up and then
they need to have um
a newspaper paper advert and if they
comply with those points
and they counsel advertising the website
it makes it uh
the other aspect whether you're
describing about how
um you know the grounds for the
objections that came in
initially they were all accepted as as
valid object
valid representations and i think
um you know clearly the application
itself
has changed throughout that process uh
to
today so uh you know the the the
representations that were initially made
were all valid and
that's what that's what's triggered the
hearing so it's not been a
a fruitless exercise it has it has
uh caused the the applicant to consider
half their their operation
okay thanks mr hinchey yeah it becomes a
negotiation really to
to satisfy all parties really and get
the best
the best situation from from the
application really so
um and that that's what that's what took
place and it
um it seems to satisfy everybody
uh mr ross can i just ask you if you'd
like to sum up please your your
application
yes um i think the only thing i can
really say is that i think that
we've we've clearly we've clearly
demonstrated that we were willing to
amend and work with not normally
licensing
officers but also and take on board the
concerns of local residents in the realm
where the
bolt's going to be moored and and quite
happily
amend our license in that application
take on conditions
um to to to alleviate any concerns
um we we will be at the end of the
telephone
and email if anyone any residents ever
take up
um an issue with us they could contact
us directly
and we'll try we'll try and um manage
any
any concerns um directly um
in the future uh it's just we're hoping
that this is
this is gonna be a long-term venture for
us and we want to make sure that it's
done right and properly
as we do with all our businesses
okay thank you mr ross that's brilliant
okay
um miss lenahan do you want to give your
briefing
now to the committee or do you want
would you rather do it in closed session
i've got nothing to add at this stage
and i'm happy to answer any questions
okay then i think we'll go we'll go into
the breakout room and then the committee
will make a decision
and then come back uh into the into the
full meeting to um to give the decision
that that we've made
do i do i need to stay around now do i
need to
it's up to you no i'm quite happy with
what mr how mr ross okay that's fine
yeah i might even buy a ticket
but now thank you for doing that it's
just it's cleared our minds a lot here
so thank you ever so much for doing that
i'm pleased that your concerns yeah
thank you
okay thanks thanks for inviting us no
problem
i mean if there are any problems we
don't envisage any but if you get in
touch with the licensing office i mean
it might be better outside the meeting
if
if you have direct contact with anybody
anything going on that shouldn't be
going on and then obviously to
let him know but yeah okay
thank you thank you very much
right um okay can we go into the
breakout room then
please for the committee
yes